what is the conjunction of the Spheres
in the world of The Witcher simply puts
is what it's like When Worlds Collide
Geralds of Rivia goes up against a
number of bloodthirsty monsters
throughout the dangerous world of
Netflix's The Witcher and these
encounters give many episodes a horrific
Flair as if that wasn't enough there's a
fact that whenever Siri screams she
unleashes other terrifying monsters from
inside the black monaves scattered
around the continent that's all without
mentioning the political Intrigue the
northern Kingdom's war with nilfgaard
and garwald's complicated romance with
Jennifer of vengerberg season 2 deepens
the law behind the continent as Jennifer
fringilla and Francesca are all wrapped
in a dark conspiracy to resurrect him a
level and demon called valoth mare the
show also briefly touches on why the
continent is crowned with humans elves
dwarves and monsters for this history it
calls back to an event long ago in the
timeline called the conjunction of the
Spheres in The Witcher books by Andre
sapkowski the conjunction of the Spheres
takes place more than a thousand years
before geral's adventures with vezamere
yennefer and sir theory in fact says the
reason why the continent is such a
dangerous place to live as The Witcher 3
wild Hunt explains our world intertwined
with another through an upheaval
Scholars call the conjunction of the
Spheres
the cataclysmic events caused different
universes to crash into one another and
it brought a countless number of other
beings into the world like all the
monsters that geralt and his friends go
up against in The Witcher it also
brought separate races of human beings
into the continent with different
languages and Customs it's survivors
lost and forsaken in a new world New To
You monsters and humans weren't the only
things that come through the conjunction
of the Spheres though the disaster also
brought magic and Chaos into the
continent eventually humans realized
they could tap into the mysterious Force
to cast spells which is how the
Brotherhood of sorceress got started
humans also decided to State their claim
on this new world for themselves and
surprise the elves of their savagery
there's a bit of law text from The
Game's recounts looking for a place in
the world humans took up arms against
the Elder races who were unable to
withstand the barbarians and ultimately
surrendered this is how humans came to
rule the world a second conjunction
briefly happens in The Witcher 3 the
wild Hunt it once again brings new
creatures into the world and even causes
the elves to leave the continent in
search of a new realm to call home
because the conjunction of the Spheres
is such a pivotal event in the history
of the continent Netflix is diving into
that era with a spin-off series called
The Witcher blood origin It sets right
right before the conjunction of the
Spheres and to look at how the Elven
Empire collapses after the disaster
takes place blood origin will also
reveal how the conjunction happened in
the first place and it'll even explain
how the first Witcher was created so
it's going to be a must watch for fans
who want to learn more about the
continent Iron Fist writer Declan
Deborah is a showrunner on blood origin
and the witches showrunner Lauren s
hisrick is also an executive producer on
the series this means it'll all fit
nicely together in the timeline and it
should hopefully answer some key
questions that fans have about the
universe his rig told Entertainment
Weekly we have obviously heard in The
Witcher show that humans brought
civilization to the elves they're the
ones who showed them what it was like to
be civilized and in fact what we're
seeing in blood origin is that's exactly
opposite of the truth Netflix was a must
and impressive cast for blood origin
including Crouching Tiger Hidden Dragon
and everything everywhere all at one
star Michelle yo in the lead role
luckily there isn't long to wait since
blood origin arrives on Chris Christmas
Day 2022